researchers have discovered how to reuse
paper by creating a printer that uses
water instead of ink so the print fades
within a day and Korea is planning to
build a new one point two three billion
dollar city that will include a theme
park and hotels for robots Vsauce Kevin
here this is mind blow scientists at the
Albert Einstein College of Medicine were
able to see how a brain makes memories
using advanced imaging techniques by
tagging memory molecules in a mouse
model with fluorescent tags eyes on
glasses let you see through skin to get
to veins vena Medical created the
glasses that work by pulsing four
different kinds of light into the skin
and then combining it into a single
composite image this gives health care
workers a clear real-time anatomically
correct image of the veins beneath the
skin to reduce issues like multiple
needle sticks the aka 24 is a future
driving concept featuring a magnetic
road you drive sideways on next to a
traditional road designed by Shuang dong
and winner of the michelin design
challenge drivers can choose to stop
controlling their vehicle and instead
ride the maglev like railroad system
once connected to the railway the car is
flipped on its side into the on driven
position where the driver would then
rotate to stay upright this robotic
ankle mimics the muscles tendons and
ligaments of the lower leg a
collaboration between Harvard University
USC MIT and BIOS n6 have developed an
orthotic device to help those with ankle
and foot injuries it uses pneumatic
artificial muscles and soft materials
that are able to act like real muscles
by expanding and contracting but work is
still being done to make it wearable for
patients peanut allergies have
essentially been cured in nine out of
ten kids with a new treatment that
gradually escalates the amount of peanut
protein the body can hang
Glyph is a mobile personal theater the
virtual retinal display uses 1 million
micro mirrors in each eyepiece and
projects images directly onto your
retina creating super sharp imagery
users can connect to their personal
content library or stream movies from a
smartphone and even use it for gaming it
can also be used as an audio device and
more like headphones and all you have to
do is pull the visor down over your eyes
to start the visual display researchers
at MIT have created a wearable book that
makes the reader feel the same
sensations that the characters in the
book are feeling it uses 150 LED lights
and a series of sensors attached to a
vest worn by the reader
during scary parts the vest contracts
around the chest and waist vibrations
occur during exciting passages to raise
the heart rate and somber moments
trigger soft dark lights this new device
is designed to harvest energy from your
organs the piezoelectric device has been
created to constantly recharge
pacemakers and other implanted devices
it's sewn directly onto the heart lungs
or diaphragm because those organs are in
constant motion
the device has nano ribbons made of
light zirconate titanate which bends
slightly as the organs move creating
small amounts of energy to power the
implanted device Triton is an oxygen
respirator concept that uses an
artificial Gill model it extracts oxygen
through a filter in the form of fine
threads with holes smaller than water
molecules and just by simply biting on
it the user is able to breathe for long
periods of time underwater just as if
they were on land removing the need to
learn how to use complicated scuba
equipment Vigo can gauge your energy
level and tell you when to nap the
wearable device monitors your alertness
throughout the day by tracking patterns
in blinks and your body's movements so
it knows when you're drowsy before you
do and it can also make suggestions on
how to change your routine to be the
most efficient based on your average
level of alertness over the course of a
day finally anti-media created an
incredible reel of footage using
cynosure owns which is an aerial camera
system
I'm gonna leave you with RINO psycho an
electric unicycle and as always thanks
for watching
we-we-we